ladies and gentlemen Michael Reeves has
ducked us for so long
so we said [ __ ] it we're gonna meet the
next best scientific man on the internet
and that's our boy be even warned ladies
and gentlemen do we say that right it's
beavin right even it's bad total [ __ ]
man sorry people are just gonna call me
bavin forever now
I mean you but you've gone that before
right I thought one like Inc you've
gotten that before now even be even ah
not really
I guess just see Bevin yeah huh yeah so
where you go ladies don't you don't know
Bevin is the man who knows more or less
how many likes we hit per episode and
that's not that's not alike in the sense
of you know tap like this is the word
like 1789 times say ìlook and when I saw
that I thought he sat here and he did
the work I can't
and no ounce of me could be upset
because it was just so funny that
someone did that so what do you feel
like after you were done with it
were you like I'm going insane from how
many times I've heard these guys say
like not really cuz I discovered your
podcast well I could take so long to get
into a podcast because yeah you kind of
have to care about people before you're
gonna listen to them so now you know
your that's cringe in music and whatnot
finally got into your full podcast and
then I noticed you know you started
saying like a lot yeah started to kind
of like bug me yeah so I thought oh [ __ ]
I'll have to make these videos Sunday
morning I get up Sunday morning
downloaded your video right from YouTube
put it into premiere and I just listened
to your podcast and just every time
so like I just cut it up it wasn't that
bad because I do enjoy listening to the
podcast yeah so if I had a height of it
I would have hated every second of it
so that actually did enjoy listening
okay let's had to sort of lay around the
larks was good yeah and then once I cut
them out then it was a pretty simple of
just like anything them all together
yeah I guess I guess that's like what we
didn't we didn't know whether or not you
were like hate listening to it yeah yeah
or if you actually liked it and you were
just taking out the likes one by one or
if you were less sitting there like I
could not yeah I could not do that I
just do not have like that much of a
care factor fish you don't care about
yeah right right yeah it's made with a
hundred percent love no I mean if we
we've sort of gotten better probably not
me it's you know man it it really made
me think is is the word like an American
thing or is that just a SoCal thing I
had it's it's much bigger I think in
strikeout yes sire
but just nowhere near as much because I
love the comments people were saying you
know you live in SoCal and some people
don't notice that at all yeah it so but
after that I started paying attention to
friends and people I know and it just
started became this whole thing in my
mind we're not getting other people's
likes well I just dominoed from there
yeah you guys definitely you triggered
something in me because once I made your
video I started because before I didn't
really hear anyone say like that much
and now other podcasts are saying I'm
hearing it more I don't hear it in
myself more it's all our fault
yes yeah I know it's weird it's a switch
isn't it it's like a menu switch once
you start hearing something or it's like
you know when you like today so I found
out you know some brand of pasta is
supposed to be really good and now I
[ __ ] see it everywhere I seeing ads
for this pasta I'm seeing in the
gardener
seen this brand of pasta ever my entire
life but once you like make that switch
yeah then your brains like oh I know
this thing now and I'm gonna start
hearing it and start seeing it
everywhere yeah it's the same thing that
with cause soon as you buy a car you see
that car everywhere yeah yeah yeah that
man that's funny though so now we're all
poisoned with the word like we can't
pretty much we just can't Maddie
yeah thanks to us and thanks to you yeah
yeah well we're mister we're Australia
do you live by the way Perth Perth oh so
we have a we're Western Australia so we
have a softer accent than the East Coast
okay so I I lived in I live in Perth I
used to live in Melbourne for a few
months then people in Melbourne thought
I was British there's my hair how's the
accent he's so soft
yeah so when you said I just got British
you know
you weren't that far off the mark okay
fair even some Australian speak I'm
British
yeah those in there are dress epic Cody
says nothing he's Australian
oh man this guy knows I use like as a
crutch in my speech and now I just
butchered his [ __ ] where he's from I
look like a total [ __ ] right now
you